[Musik]
es ist 8:10 Uhr auf dem
Sonntag
und wir sind freiwillig wach denn wir
laufen jetzt
Halbmarathon für mich ist es einfach
wichtig das unmenschliche im Körper zu
suchen und sich selbst diese Aufgabe zu
stellen sch wir sind gerade auf dem Weg
zur Bahn weil der ST in Deut ist und
laufen gerade über die Ringe und hier
müssen wir tatsächlich nachher auch lang
hi Nell hallo du läufst auch mit ne
[Musik]
nein es ist ja auch gerade eine ganz wde
Mischung zwischen Leuten die gerade
anscheinend vom Feiern kommen und wir
die auf dem Weg zum Halbmarathon
[Musik]
sind wei
nicht
[Musik]
gerade auf sind ja nur deutsche h sind
ja nur allm überall man sieht da oben
einfach noch den Mond daen wird übrigens
DS gedreht gefragt Problem ist auch dass
wir so unvorbereitet hier reingehen dass
wir nicht mal wissen wie wir uns
aufwärmen sollen wir kopieren die ganze
Zeit Übung von irgendwelchen
anderen also ich
nicht auch so Leute mit die so extra
laufbrillen haben oder so
umschnallgürtel mit so Drinks und so
diger wir haben Gefühl nicht me T-Shirt
es geht los Freunde ich laufe mein
ersten Marathon also Halbmarathon
eigentlich hallo hallo viel Glück
Idioten wir laufen jetzt gerade über die
sonnbrücke also ich glaub D dasücke ist
deerid al
oder irgendwie so sind wir so langsam
sind jetzt am Rudolfplatz ausauer top
aber mein rechtes Knie die ganze Zeit
weg ich weiß nicht ob ich irgwier wie so
eine Spinne geschlafen habe oder was
Phase ist aber augen zu und durch
junge wir sind jetzt knapp vom F
Kilometer und geht mal top ich weiß
nicht ob so sinnvoll ich zwischendurch
die ganze Zeit laber und rede und vogge
aber hey
Yolo
[Musik]
die Hälfte haben wir zeinhb
km Zwischenfazit hier stehen extrem
viele Leute am Rand mit Schildern wo
Lauf drauf steht danke für den
[Musik]
Hinweis sind jetzt bei 13 km oder so
ja ich Date W AK gerade Lauf jetzt auf
jeden Fall über die Ringe gerade und ich
meine das SP schon an ne hier schon
überall irgendwelche frauencke die
wahrscheinlich gestern Z saufen waren
und uns jetzt
anfeuern
hallo jetzt laufen wir gerade die fenler
Straße das ist so z die schlimmste
Straße in ganz Köln h passieren jeden
Tag würde ich sagen durchschnittlich 7
Milliarden Fahrradunfälle weil guck e
Fahrad an oder der 20 cm breit ach so
welchen Kilometer haben wir
ich habe lasas verloren ir Kranke
Seitenstiche meinte ich soll
weiterlaufen meine beiden Knie
explodieren mein linker Fuß GLB der ist
abgesegt ich B auch nicht mehr
aber 3 km mit P von 5 Minuten 20 oder so
gelaufen schon sehr
gutp Freunde 21 km ich blende euch hier
mal die Zeit ein 6 Minuten 9 oder so
haben wir glaube ich gebraucht das
Problem ist wir haben uns die Zeit ein
bisschen dumm eingeteilt wir waren wir
haben uns auf jeden Fall die Kraft so
ein bisschen dumm eingeteilt weil wir zu
Beginn richtig locker losgelaufen sind
weil wir haben halt eigentlich nicht so
wirklich gefrühstückt waren gestern
Abend auch noch unterwegs wir sind halt
die ersten 10 km würde ich sagen mit
einer pace von 630 gelaufen also
wirklich sehr sehr entspannt das Problem
war dann allerdings dass uns irgendwann
bei kilomet 12 13 aufgefallen ister wir
können deutlich schneller und sind dann
halt die Kilometer danach nur noch mit
einer P mit unter 6 Minuten gelaufen
oder so wie gesagt habade eingeblendet
das hat mein T-Shirt voll kaputt gemacht
so oder so muss ich sagen es war schon
geil war auf jeden Fall eine
Herausforderung war mal cool SAS zu
machen ich noch nie gemacht ich nie
verstanden warum man sowas macht weil
man kann auch etfach so laufen was man
aber sagt und ich habe 80 € dafür
bezahlt dass ich hier mit Laufen
durftead irendwelche Leute drum rum klar
man hat ein bisschen Drinks und so
bekommen aber es war schon echt
hartteuer dafür dass man auch so einfach
laufen gehen kann die Sache ist
allerdings d langweiliger Sport ist man
muss nichts können um joggen zu gehen
man muss einfach nur laufen es hat
nichts mit Skill zu tun was allerdings
ganz cool ist ist dass du wirklich die
ganze Zeit nur positive Energie hast von
den Leuten also keiner ist irgendwie
negativ keiner kann nicht irgendwie
faulen oder wie bei anderen Sportarten
nicht irgendwie davon abhalten irgendwas
zu schaffen es geht nur um dich
[Musik]
selbst
nind Scheiße hast du neuen Rucksack
diger steht
ihr ein
ST
hallo also ich war jetzt gerade duschen
und ich muss mich tatsächlich noch mal
korrigieren das was am meisten weh tut
ist nicht mein Knie sonder meine
verdammten
Nippel die sind auch richtig rot ich
habe so ein unterhemt angehabt das hat
so
[Musik]
gescheuert wunderschönes
Ambiente Eier Eier Eier Eier wir
brauchen Eier größer SC gibt
größter
scam also falls sie mitbekommen hab wir
sind im Stadion und Köln schieß jetzt
ein
Tor oh die hab echt was geschossen
dainten ich bin jetzt rüber gekommen
weil das erst Spiel beim ersten FC köl
S N das ist nicht mein erstes Spiel hier
ja ich bin schon super oft hier gewesen
Nummer ein was woll du sagen ich sch
immer alles raus wenn du dir nicht was
sagen
will e Christian willst was zu meinem
Blog
sagen W mein Block Stuttgart hat 2
gewonnen wir feiern jetzt hier der
stuttgartan und freut sich mir geht's
nicht so gut zeig mal deine neuen
Tattoos FC erstmal tätowiert okay cool
oder zeig mal das
andere
nein ich w ich wollte du wolltest das
nicht wollteoll hast du dir die Skyline
von Köln
tätowiert ist das
Köln boah das haben wir uns so verdient
ne nedy euer lieblingsvlogger laserlaca
würde an der Stelle den heutigen Blog
jetzt auch beenden wir haben tatsächlich
gar nicht mehr viel gemacht außer eine
Menge gegessen und Filme geguckt von
daher was das da euch eh nicht gefallen
hat brauch ich gar nicht sagen dass ihr
mich abonnieren müsst
und ja ich kann kein von euch entfehlen
halb zu laufen mir tut alles weh